Imagine you're planning
a trip up the coast,
but instead of driving,
you decide to hop into a vehicle
shaped like a giant aluminum can.
Your heart pounds
as you strap yourself in.
The air is stagnant.
Beads of sweat are pooling on your brow
as you prepare to launch.
The vehicle starts to move.
Before you know it,
you're going 500 miles per hour.
You hope that the people in control
know what they're doing.
Turns out that's just your average
airplane experience.
And 118 years ago,
before the Wright brothers' first flight,
the thought of humans flying
was inconceivable -- crazy, even.
Yet today, we get into a plane,
30,000 feet above the ground,
and think nothing of it.
A year after the Wright brothers'
historic first flight,
another inventor, an American physicist
called Robert Goddard,
proposed an entirely new
form of transportation:
the vactrain.
He envisioned a high-speed
mass transit system
where people would travel on the ground,
with little to no air resistance,
inside of a tube.
And today, these are some
of the earliest renderings
of what we call a hyperloop.
So for those of you
unfamiliar with the hyperloop,
this is the chance we get
to geek out together a bit.
So hyperloop is a transit system
that has a vehicle called a pod
inside of a tube about the same size
as a subway tunnel,
where we suck most, but not all
of the air out of it,
making it the equivalent of flying
at about 200,000 feet of altitude.
This allows us to glide at airline speeds,
without turbulence,
for a fraction of the energy consumption,
about one tenth,
to be precise, of an aircraft.
And that's important,
because we, as humans,
have an innate need for speed.
But this obsession with speed and volume
is destroying the planet around us.
In fact, in the United States,
the transportation industry
is the single largest contributor
to greenhouse gas emissions.
A hyperloop system
can begin to change this trend
before the end of the decade,
by transforming short-haul
journeys and commutes
from hours to minutes.
Our system is inspiring
a new category of companies
dedicated to bringing this to life.
But it's going to take
more than just vision.
History's full of ideas
that have flopped and flourished,
and this one’s just too important
for us not to get right.
So I am an engineer,
and I am insatiably curious
and always love a good problem.
So in 2013, when Elon Musk released
the "Hyperloop Alpha" white paper,
of course, I was going to give it a read.
It sketched out an idea
with an open invitation
for anyone to take it from a concept
and design it to reality.
We decided to not only make it tangible
but make it safe, sustainable
and economically viable.
And we were so convinced
that we could make it work
that I quit my job to build it.
I thought I was being optimistic.
My wife, on the other hand,
thought I was completely delusional.
Either way, we heard over and over
that building a functional
hyperloop was unrealistic.
But for each "no" we heard,
we dove deeper and deeper
into the science and the engineering
and showed that it was in fact possible,
but it was going to be no easy feat for us
to build something that had never existed.
So our early prototypes
started with the traditional concept
that maglev uses,
that is, where the track
controls the vehicle.
But something about that
just wasn't quite right
for a hyperloop system.
So for months,
I had been noodling on how to make
our system future-proof.
And while I was on a bike ride
in the mountains above Los Angeles,
I came around a bend.
A 1933 Ford Roadster
followed by a Tesla Model S passed me.
Those two cars are light-years
different in technology,
yet they drive on the same passive road.
And there it was.
Smart vehicle, dumb road.
Or in the case of a hyperloop,
smart pod, dumb tube.
So technology has made it possible
that a car can be modular,
upgradeable and future-proof,
while the road stays pretty much the same.
So for a hyperloop, our tube
is passive and simple, like the road,
but our modular pods can evolve
as technology advances,
just like the automobile.
So we now had our vision.
The next thing we had to do
is assemble the team.
So we've all seen a "Mission Impossible"
movie in this room,
and there's always a scene in those movies
where someone lays out
a task or plan calmly.
But what they lay out
is completely and totally insane.
So for a hyperloop,
our mission that we've chosen to accept
is to build the world's largest
vacuum structures,
devise new passive magnetic guideways,
create pods capable of withstanding
a space environment,
powered by next-generation batteries
while levitating using
state-of-the-art magnetic levitation,
while quietly accelerating,
using the world's most efficient
linear electric motor.
(Laughter)
Everyone turns to the engineer.
I have to make that possible,
or we have to make that possible.
Luckily for us,
we have more than just one
of those engineers,
we have a few hundred that have designed
reusable rockets, spaceships,
autonomous aircraft,
electric vehicles, AI systems
and loads of other cool things.
And after building that system,
we created a test track
in the desert outside of Las Vegas.
We've operated the system over 500 times
and had countless other tests
on our subsystems.
But there was one test
that was going to be the defining moment
for hyperloop technology:
the first passengers in the vehicle.
And we were going to do it
with regular people
that didn't need years
of training and experience
to set foot inside of a space capsule.
So by October of 2020,
we had run hundreds of tests,
some with these extremely handsome
mannequins that you see here.
We had an independent safety auditor
give us the green light,
but still, it was nerve-racking.
We were boldly going
where only these handsome
mannequins had gone before.
And on November 8th, 2020,
we made our first attempt.
So at our test site,
my colleague Sara and I
climbed into that can-like vehicle
suspended by magnetic levitation
at a near-vacuum environment,
and the countdown began.
In those 15 seconds,
we showed the world that what was deemed
ludicrous over 100 years ago
was in fact possible.
That brief moment has opened
so many doors for us.
We've had conversations
in the US, Europe, India, the Middle East,
about building hyperloop systems
in the next 10 years.
This is the start of a systemic change
in the way we travel.
Simply put,
society has moved forward,
as we've moved faster.
The railroad ushered in
the industrial revolution,
the airplane forever changed
the way we move.
But today, we’re at an inflection point.
Nations around the world are looking
for ways to reduce carbon emissions,
but at the same time,
we need to get where we're going
in minutes, not hours.
We also need to invest in infrastructure
that can meet the needs
of the 21st century, and beyond.
And so my hope for a hyperloop system
is that it can transform
the way that we live --
we can live where we want to live,
work where we want to work,
we can create a world
in which your daughter,
who lives in Los Angeles,
can go surfing in Santa Cruz
and be home in time for lunch.
A world in which 150 million people
can live in Mumbai and travel to Pune,
the equivalent distance
of Philadelphia to New York,
in 30 minutes, not four hours,
while saving 1.1 million tons
of pollution each and every year.
The last century started
with two people riding on a plane,
and it ended with millions of people
flying all over the world.
This decade started with two people
riding on a hyperloop system,
and my hope is that by the end of it,
you'll ride one too.
Thank you.
(Applause)